j'accueille maintenant les robins des
bois
les robins des bois 2 des robins des
bois marina foïs
bonsoir et jean paul rouve bonsoir je
vais raconter un petit peu votre vie 1 1
voilà les robins des bois se sont
rencontrés au cours d' isabelle nanty et
puits sans fond d une troupe qui
s'appelait le royaume imperial green
rabbit compagnie et là vous écrivez
ensemble un spectacle qui s'appelle
robin des bois d'à peu près alexandre
dumas et c'est là que dominique farrugia
vous remarque et quand il crée sa chaîne
sur le câble et le satellite comédie il
vous engage cette fois sous le nom des
robins des bois pour la grosse émission
la salle a duré deux ans deux ans de pur
bonheur
et puis ensuite vous avez sur canal npa
là c'est un peu moins sympa pourquoi
parce que le public comprend mal votre
humour et ça se passe très bien avec
nagui qui vous a passé souvent du
programme non non non c'est pas ça non
mais ça se passait bien canal en plus à
bord s'est bien marré la nec nagui ça
s'est plutôt bien passé
c'est vrai qu'on était happé quelquefois
en fin d'année à parce qu'il y avait du
retard
ah bon d'accord ce problème qu'on a
toujours et je crois que malheureusement
l'heure à toute notre vie c'est que les
jeux ils n'arrivent jamais à nous et mis
tout de suite je peux pas vous expliquer
pourquoi mais on a remarqué que les gens
commencent à avoir un petit peu de
tendresse pour nous au bout de 70 72
sketch jamais avant
il faut une amérique et nous le prouve
que tenir les 62 bon j'allais mieux
quand même l'année d'après avec du
jambon puis c'était l'année de l'instant
norvégien dont vous sortez un best-of en
cassettes et dvd vous savez comment on
fait ouais
moi
et et le chant
comment de ce mois
je vous aime
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
m
en voici jean paul rouve
[Musique]
commandant jean-paul super est-ce que tu
as croisé marilyn manson vaincu la la
ouais ouais en fait mary max aussi parce
que c'est quoi c'est le fils de jane
manson de sessa avec richard berry c'est
l'enfance celle enfants qu'ils ont eus
avec richard berry
je pense à k presse ont dit adieu
tu sais que c'est le futur gendre de
chantal d'affaires djigo des lance
flammes tandis que je reste bien sûr
paul alors jean paul je vais être obligé
de te vous voyez là encore si ces genres
l'interview et oui je comprends alors
jean paul bonsoir vous avez reçu le 22
février le césar du meilleur jeune
espoir masculin bon ouais
bonventre rôle public bien sûr dans
monsieur batignole de gérard jugnot jean
baudron voit émerger du soir désormais
bien j'ai l'histoire c'est vrai jeunes
gens sont cons donc tout le monde croit
jean paul que vous avez inventé ça comme
ça au dernier moment au micro pour
dégeler l'atmosphère mais pas du tout
c'était c'était poelvoorde qui avait
demandé à la petite depardieu de vous
toucher l'écho exactement parce qu'on on
à tourner dans le même film non au
podium et julie fait la femme de benoît
et à lui comme s'il savait que les
hommes et à leur mettez le césar du
jeune espoir
elle lui a dit si jamais c'est jean paul
tu touchais courrier laval delà de la
robe est prévu cette vanne d'entrée et
évidemment il ya les couilles avant et
ça a planté là ça a planté la vente de
la robe
j'aime frej leurs frais la rochelle pour
un 7 d'or ont aboli aux grands comptes
ça fait quoi d'être enfin je vais pas
dire meilleurs jeunes espoirs mes
meilleurs espoirs du cinéma français
tout bonnement est quoi ca fait plaisir
ouais ça fait super plaisir et se faire
plaisir super plaisir plaisir
vous validez à gérer dakar eh ben c'est
bien
c'est un grand plaisir tu te la pètes un
peu non lundi ça tombe mal va faire
l'interview je me la pète seconde
jeunesse et se gausse faut que je me la
pète faut que tu te la pètes la touche
la tête haute et dakar alors maintenant
jean paul rouve que votre talent est
reconnu
est-ce que vous allez laisser tomber la
bande de guignols avec laquelle vous
traînez l'appui les robins là je pense
que là on va tourner d'autres films
ensemble
je pense que voilà ces derniers quoi
c'est la fin ouais c'est un petit peu la
fin j'ai un peu de mal à maintenant de
jouer avec eux sont pas au goût du jour
ouais d'accord c'est vrai que vous
refusez de vous montrer avec marina
parce qu'elle a pas eu de césar oui
parce qu'elle a passé un cap à de st ces
deux raisons est-ce que leurs troupes
l'aller les robins c'est ça est ce que
ça peut survivre si vous êtes plus non
je pense pas cela c'est pas possible
c'est génial mais je doute au fait
jean-paul compte tenu de votre nouveau
statut maintenant ça vous gave de venir
faire de la promo comme ça sur les
plateaux de télé ça doit vous j'essaie
la dernière fois je pense que je viens
chez vous par exemple un trop populaire
ouais je ferais bompard journal de 20
heures c'est tout bien sûr vous auriez
quels conseils à donner à un jeune
acteur qui débute par exemple eelv henri
moi je croyais ventes us et simplement
sois toi même tout simplement que
j'essaie d'être simple enfin regarde mes
films si tu as envie tout simplement qui
arrive
il paraît que les roues de rêve de vous
là vous allez y aller non je sais pas
encore je vais voir franchis et quand
même à téléphoner lewis arts à quoi les
américains les américains un mois j'ai
dit que si je peux tourner en français
est alors maintenant vous voulez coucher
avec qui mais vous êtes quand même césar
mais c'était bien de février les césar 1
on est quand même au mois d'avril je
sais qu'il me reste que les que léa par
danielle darrieux je crois que je fais
partie vous voulez quoi là maintenant je
voulais un truc on vous le donne
qu'est-ce qui va je crois que j'ai un
peu tout gégé le succès j'ai physique je
crois qu'on est tout seul j'ai j'entends
relâche aussi pourquoi je crois que j'ai
un peu tout j'ai l'argent j'ai des
voitures merci beaucoup monsieur rouve
c'était un honneur pour moi
[Musique]
le boulot vous êtes ici pour le film de
richard berry qui s'appelle moi césar 10
ans et demi à m 39 où vous avez retrouvé
on y revient toujours le petit jules
sitruk le petit garçon de monsieur
batignole le film qui vous a valu un
oscar
monsieur rouve monsieur rouge voilà
alors c'est deuxième film de richard
berry c'est l'histoire de césar donc dix
ans et demi à m 39 5 kilos en trop le
petit lui ont mis des prothèses
oui c'était même dur je croyais tout
bascula il avait des irritations et tout
ça un enfer à paris voilà le petit les
fous amoureux de sarah qui est jouée par
joséphine berry la fille de richard
berry a et non pas avec jeane manson
cette fois mais avec jesse cas ford
voilà faisons l'amour avant de nous dire
je les publie dans ses comptes il serait
bienvenu si tu pas nous le chantait nom
faisant la moue avant de nous dire adieu
oui oui
cicolella
bien fini nos deux ils ne sentent bien
le bougre
leveaux moitié l'ont vraiment un beau
bordel
cet homme est un génie mais ça faisait
lui disons robben
alors donc ce petit ce petit césar donc
fois amoureux de sarah il n'a aucune
chance face à son meilleur ami m'a
beaucoup yaté voilà ça c'est son rival
qu'un métis blond comme ça magnifique et
cet univers de césar et des cris et
c'est toute l'idée du film à hauteur des
yeux d'un enfant voilà ce qui fait que
dans ça donne une impression qu'on n'a
pas connue depuis très longtemps
qu'est-ce qu'on le voit on tue voilà
voilà 22 voix les couilles voilà vous
avez un look un peu à la mia frye
dreadlocks vous dit
happy face happy face happy face à face
tout le temps deux champions body ouais
je te le dire bouge ton corps ouais
voilà vous faites bien et je suis prof
de je suis prof de gym en fait et
j'entraîne les enfants je fais une
chorégraphie pour les enfants mais je
leur parle comme s'il avait 15 ans de
danse et ses deux enfants de 8 ans
peuvent alors il s'est pointé sur
l'annexé jean-paul oui une question qui
pourra vous semblez peut-être un petit
peu discrètement
hassam avec vous est ce cas quelqu'un
qui vous attend le soir chez vous quand
vous rentrez non je suis je suis je suis
je peux faire une annonce ou pas hier je
veux bien mais j'ai personnes qui
m'attend donc avec les yeux vous avez
vous avez vous avec moi maintenant je
sais pas c'est si bizarre je pisse fine
nous avait les cheveux longs c'est pas
c'est ça en fait
donc oui donc je fais je peux faire une
annonce officielle ou chercher un
animateur ou une animatrice a quand même
de préférence
voilà je fais une erreur vous pouvez
m'appeler vous appelez la danse et la
prod jean paul donne tranche d'âge c'est
un conseil est fascinant à 85,19 entre
dit non ça trop vieille entre dix huit
et dix huit et demi blood bowl et
beaucoup d'expérience d'expérience
nombre us à 101 beaucoup d'expérience et
une fille ça me fait super plaisir
voilà la semaine dernière enfin il ya
quinze jours on a marié godrèche et
d'armand godrèche et d'armes il m'a fait
ça d'art où il a tué tout le monde et
maillot
mais quand vous voyez pas dans le groupe
b qui je donne et flore amour
le
ainsi alain chabat et jean paul rouve
[Musique]
voilà
jean paleron mesdames messieurs
[Applaudissements]
laurent incident
c'est très gentil
merci beaucoup à ce moment
et et et et l'eau et leurs mamans
ouais
votre ménage bonsoir acier nouvelle a
bien sûr c'est jeudi jabbar de nom de
faire des petits quand même ses formes
il a dit clara est là à la haye la
us-china heureusement vous espériez pas
tant qu'entité dont je pensais pas qu'il
était comment petit à petit j'ai par
ailleurs du gros un peu plus grand isle
il avait pas la moustache célèbre états
unis il avait déjà des tendances à être
pas les mêmes que maintenant peut-être
qui est aussi maman tu t'es sorti de
l'alcool en fait pas maintenant parce
que qu'est-ce qui on attend les gens
sont sales choqué quand vous allez
chercher à l'école quand on était petits
c'était bourré devant les lycées gomis a
souffert de ça or il ne faut plus en
parler parce que sa valeur ouais en bixi
c'est sûr ils se tirent toujours sur
l'élastique s'est rien passé
bah oui
à quel âge il a commencé à l'un
j'ai mis un an et demi oui un peu un peu
retardé c'est plutôt mais c'est vrai
qu'il avait le bouton rouge toujours oui
c'est une non il était en veille déjà un
chien qui fait dire à bondir si ta mère
et vous rappelle que roselyne est
également la maman de eric et ramzy
qu'on embrasse au passage on vous dit au
revoir
[Applaudissements]
on va les finir tout à l'heure
dans la loge après l'émission bref
maintenant pas le moment
je m'en fous et rendre ces câbles a mis
ses mots
c'est un gros
en prévision à
cvc boula montbrial
sans surprise elle s'offrir
rigoler ma mère ouais ouais je ne savais
pas qu'elle était gohier du bien alors
vous êtes ici pour la sortie d'un des
films les plus attendus de l'année qui
s'apaise
voilà donc c'est un film écrit par ils
ont fait exprès non fait pour ça c'est
fait pour sa mort kanak est servi à
acheter les billets ce sera bon jour
jouer une place pour donc un film qui
est écrit par les robins en
collaboration avec alain chabat joué par
les robins et alain chabat plus
depardieu rochefort valérie lemercier
dominique farrugia font des apparitions
pour le mérite originaire de la région
voilà et réalisé par alain chabat alors
le pitch je vais le faire je crois que
ce sera beaucoup plus simple
le pitch pas d'avoir le fond c'est le
premier thriller préhistorique
nous sommes en pleine préhistoire moins
trente cinq mille ans avant jésus-christ
et pour la première fois un crime est
commis
c'est la première fois qu'un homme tue
un autre homme alors pourquoi tu es qui
a tué
c'est pour ça que j'ai dit le premier
thriller préhistorique soit première
fois que que va faire se pose est au
niveau de la forme c'est beaucoup moins
métaphysique mais c'est le premier
dessin animé dans les personnages sont
des vrais acteurs je crois qu'on peut le
dire
1 j'aime bien ouais c'est gentil mais si
c'est marina qu'a dit ça alors là donc
et la tribu des cheveux sales qui veut
voler le secret du shampoing à la tribu
des cheveux propres et ce qu'elle le
vaut bien
voilà
et alors tout le monde s'appelle pierre
parce qu'on est à l'âge de pierre qui
les animaux évidemment il ya des des
poules goutte chez les canards mousse et
puis il y avait vermouth qu'on a ici
derrière voilà ça c'est une espèce de
petite poule rousse
c'est une poule rousse laurent voilà si
ça c'est quoi ça leur coûte ça c'est
ailleurs
ces cochons moutons c'est le lapin
moudre énergie ma le lapin mouthe et
puis il ya le foot
lorsque voilà donc ça se passe comme ça
on goûte ya des mammouths mais pas de
mode voilà c'est porte nawak en fait
c'est c'est tout non s'est basé sur des
faits réels et il ya eu beaucoup de
recherches sur le sur le sujet notamment
retrouvé sa grande époque
vous avez retrouvé des documents des
blancs bien sûr un puisque la couleur
n'existe pas à l'époque
voyez donc forcément les enregistrements
d'assez mauvaise qualité mais qui nous
ont quand même permis de travail et une
base une base coiffe un devoir à la
véracité
voilà des bien sûr et beaucoup de drogue
avec le personnage du vous appelez le
blond non mais vous m'appelez pierre
j'aime pas qu'on appelle le blond super
malin lui santé un petit peu différent
des autres ah oui c'est d'ailleurs c'est
un film sur la différence je crois qu'il
faut le dire tout de suite voilà je suis
seule blonde la tribu et je vis je vis
assez mal la différence pour ça que je
suis un personnage un peu renfermé
c'est un peu un personnage et la clau de
sauter dans le film que j'attends
quelque chose quelque chose de sauter
mais sans romy schneider et michel
piccoli mais bon un drame rural
c'est un personnage assez assez épais au
milieu de tout ça un personnage un peu
tourmenté voilà un peu ton monte c'est
la première fois que je fais ce genre de
personnage
ouais je suis très content mais c'est le
plus remarqué mais oui
malheureusement jamais bah voilà si si
je vais travailler fort mais j'ai eu du
mal à faire sur scène donc c'est chabal
et robin j'ai déjà dit trois fois sortie
nationale le 28 janvier 700 copies
sûrement un cinéma près de chez vous
qu'il le joue parce que 700 copies c'est
énorme non oui oui si le savent pas de
vanne [ __ ] pas de vannes
ouais c'est sa copie par rapport à ces
beaucoup vous comptez faire quand même
entré à la à peu près avec ce bon film
précédent a fait 14 millions et demi
d'entrées de se faire doubler
ouais donc je pense qu'on va faire à la
voilà ce qu'on va faire
est-ce qu'on va perdre ce sera plus sûr
on va faire plusieurs prises en juillet
vous comptez faire comme un mantra que
j'allais me répondre d'abord 14,6
millions quand il faire quand même très
bas à 14,6 millions là où maintenant
vous me dire si millions je vais faire
comme l entrée vous voulez le vrai
chiffre non je veux le chinois puis je
prendrai la meilleure prise d'accord en
fonction des entrées quand on voit ça
comme ça comme ça vous aurez raison vous
aurez toujours présent d'ailleurs dit
moi 6 millions alors je vais faire quand
même entré 6 millions 6 millions mais on
va refaire encore immense il omet un
troisième pour moi oui comme elle en
train et que dire de 2 milliards alors
laurent tu as fait quand même montré ton
film 2 milliards
[Applaudissements]
des milliards de milliards ce sont les
pertes de la production en anciens
francs on en tiendra là
[Applaudissements]
quand tu vas me faire 180 milles en tête
c'est faire comme l entrée 180000 comme
d'affilée alors est ce que vous êtes
attaché de presse sont là oui bien sûr
je crois que vous viviez myriam et
myriam myriam et n'a rien mais la très
bien et que myriam on va leur faire
plaisir on va faire les questions du
dossier de presse comme ça ou pas il n'y
aura pas de dire a pas de problème mais
on est sûr que vous vous rendrez le pied
alors comment êtes vous arrivé sur ce
projet alain chabat c'est amusant que
vous me posiez cette question
comme comme producteur d'abord dominique
farrugia qui devait initialement
produire le film a été appelé pour
diriger canal+
bon ce poste allée lui prendre 120 % de
son temps il m'a donc contact avec les
robins des bois pour savoir si je
voulais produire c'est bien non mais ça
fait vraie mission de cinéma je me
connais vraiment j'adore bien le terrain
les gens ne sont pas habitués à la
spontanéité chez vous avoir du plaisir à
jouer même avec la pression de votre
double fonction alain chabat vous
réalisez que vous jouez sur février
mission de cinéma là c'est une bonne
question que personne n'a jamais posé ça
me fait plaisir
ardisson bon j'adore jouer j'adore
réaliser mais c'est vrai que les deux en
même temps n'était pas mon exercice
favori tout dire les jours où je faisais
acteur réalisateur
gt gt d'une humeur de dôme août
c'est très désagréable pour l'équipe
entre parenthèses qu'elle soit remerciée
pour sa patience mais ça m'a bien aidé
pour le rôle très bien
n'aurait-il pas été plus simple de
trouver le film en studio alors on ya
pensé et puis finalement jean rochefort
accepté ouais
alain de souvenirs garderez-vous de
l'horreur vas-y un sétois j'ai entendu à
laon début de la question alain chabat à
quels souvenirs garderez-vous de haut et
il y en a beaucoup tout ce joyeux liés
au bonheur de travailler avec des gens
décidés à donner le meilleur
quant aux robins il travaille autant
qu'ils déconnent ils ce sont de très
gros bosseur
merci alors jean paul et nous préoccupe
et vous et vous et vous et vous attend
vincent les figurants juste après l'été
durant le témoignage de figurants une
forme de jean paul raconte c'est pas ça
jean paul à la plage non plus jean-paul
à l'érection ces paroles sont l'espagne
terrestres non jean pierre tribouillard
et vous on s'inspire excusez moi l'école
jean paul pourquoi dans tout processus
d'énergie l'envol
[Musique]
mont sainte anne et touchant
trois ans pendant des mois la les homo
sapiens tentant léboutou 100 euros
d'amendé extrait de la bo du film alors
sur la bo yahia joey starr ya ophélie
winter il ya fabuleux aussi à busta flex
ya superbus ouais on l'aimé bien c'est
flatteur jenny finale et bien non il ya
le making of en papier alors ça c'est
extraordinaire
donc il ya le scénario il pour ben voilà
ça c'est vraiment ton fils adore
laurenti la bible les jeux wii grave
il avait couvert les répliques il ya le
scénario original il ya les storyboards
vous dessinez très bien monsieur chabat
merci tient vraiment et puis à des
photos aussi du tournage enfin cet
extrait i'm a man nu et puis elle et
puis à les peluches aussi évidemment les
bienvenus interview sans la bouche
[Musique]
jean-paul interviews sont la bouche
attention ne dit rien vous êtes dans une
soirée claude berri vous vous salue en
vous appelant jean pierre rives
vous êtes obligé de sourire parce que
c'est claude berri vous souriez comme
alain dans la même soirée nicolas
sarkozy arrive vous salue vous parle
vous félicite
un photographe arrive fait quelle tête
sur la photo jean-paul à ce moment là
une sublime gonzesses entre ne regarde
que vous vous êtes inaccessible fait
quelle tête inaccessible mais pas trop
inaccessible mais pas trop ouais mais
pas trop inaccessible inaccessible à je
suis excessivement au patro pas trop
à la nicole kidman arrive dans cette
soirée où il ya claude berri déjà
nicolas sarkozy aimait ça s'apprécie et
alors vous voient comme c'est fait aïe
alan vous faites quoi vous mondial le
feront parce que c'est kidman excuses il
dit qu'est ce qui fait que ce blaireau
jean-paul vous vous croisez quelqu'un de
visiblement important en fait vous
l'avez pas reconnu c'est le nouveau
comics et alain delon fait quelle tête
jamais vécu jean paul jean pierre guérin
le producteur de julie lescaut vous
raconte vos débuts dans la série il vous
propose de revenir dans la série julie
lescaut à un million de francs l'épisode
pizza pizza pizza merde millions de
francs épisode alors vous embarquez
nicole kidman on est lui dis moi je
rencontre jean pierre guérin julie
lescaut capitale qui n'a selon marc
nicole kidman federer en même temps vous
prenez votre voiture vous avez pour un
dernier verre au costes et là vous lui
dites nicole contrairement à ce que tout
le monde croit je ne suis pas d'oran je
suis américain kader aoun je t'emmerde
ça c'est pour commencer
oui moi quand je fais l'américain je
suis un peu classe fait comme c'est un
peu comme à
jean-paul ont quitté vers soi rien de
toujours vous en avez marre des travaux
sur marion gamme ghezzal et vous allez
au cost ouais il vous rencontrer alain
chabat et nicole kidman qui sont en
train de prendre un dernier verre il
fait l'américain vous vous asseyez vous
êtes là tous les trois ou gréco et d'un
seul coup
ophélie winter arrive chez bonjour ofili
back home show that enrichi je peux en
parler et l'allemand demande pourquoi
bah si c'est un truc et qu'ardisson pas
dire bonjour normalement
le
mais en bas
le bar du genre
valérie lemercier de l'unita
à l'heure
joe et c'est
pensez vous
[Musique]
certains agents par la gent ballon
cheikh lahlou et ses oliviers il a un
don pour embrouiller les invités c'est
sûr que c'est un coût qui fait de jeu
quand les invités arrivent il fait bien
démago l'es1 et puis comme tous les ans
on m'a dit m si ça c'est pas de l'amour
bon jean paul rouve bonsoir bonsoir
bonsoir
alors je garde quelques arrière merci
merci nous arrange bien pour jean-paul
alors après monsieur batignole podium
reut et un long dimanche de fiançailles
et les clefs de bagnole électrique
alors c'est qui cite les grands films
c'est vrai c'est vrai on vous retrouve
dans un petit jeu sans conséquence de
bernard rapp et là vous êtes moins bien
qu'à ses jeux c'est pas la chute la
drogue je crois plutôt ce médecin avec
sandrine kiberlain marina foïs yvan
attal et lionel abelanski sortie le 15
décembre à la hanche et le pitch
invasive à zioui on va voir si bien le
pays change et yvan attal vie avec
sandrine kiberlain importe quoi il avec
charlotte la mussara la basse et voilà
ça c'est le pitch moderne or le pitch
moderne dans l'ancien pitchoune dit
alain serge machin on comprend dans le
pitch moderne on donne le nom de
l'acteur comme protagoniste du film
c'est le pitch d'aujourd'hui laurent
voilà rang qui vend attal effectivement
été avec sandrine kiberlain
c'est le pitch black and n'est pas dans
la vraie sur l'autre cela dit baisse
tous un peu ensemble dans le showbiz 1-1
va savoir ce qui m'aura bien avec avec
sandrine kiberlain depuis douze ans et
au cours d'une journée dans une
propriété à la campagne tous les proches
sont sont conviés ils font semblant par
jeu de se séparer
et là c'est horrible dire qu'il découvre
que personne ne croit à leur couple et
tout le monde leur dis bah oui
finalement effectivement on attend fin
on n'a jamais compris pourquoi vous
étiez ensemble c'est mieux comme ça et
tout donc ils découvrent que personne
n'y croit et si terrible parce que ce
petit jeu sans conséquence a des
conséquences
c'est dire qu'à un moment
marina foïs dit à sandrine kiberlain
qu'elle a couché avec son jules avec
avec yvan attal donc évidemment ça jette
un froid qui maintenant non vous êtes
séparés je peux te le dire je me le suis
tapé donc j'imagine qu'en allemand et
vous jean paul rouve qui est l'ennemi
d'enfance d' yvan attal son meilleur
ennemi mais poussés dans les temps même
si vous dites le contraire pendant tout
le film devrait pousser aussi il est si
nous crever l'oeil bon sang qu'est une
vieille haine qui rôdent entre vous deux
et vous draguez sandrine kiberlain voilà
est donc ce petit jeu sans conséquence
et plein de conséquences
je ne dirais pas la fin mais ça vaut le
coup c'est une une belle histoire ça
commence comme ça comme un dimanche à la
campagne puis s'est servi d'une façon
assez assez amer ac est grand c'est ça
oui un don qui divorcent hupond non sipa
faron c'est pas bon ça ne veut pas dire
non mais je ne veux pas dire fais pas
dire je veux pas dire je veux pas dire
voilà alors il ya une scène il ya
beaucoup de scènes vous êtes formidable
mais il ya une scène soul a sous la
gloriette où vous faites frire sandrine
kiberlain
on est excellent merci thierry
maintenant excellent si gentil non mais
moi je vous avais dit a longtemps que je
trouvais un très bon acteur
et là vous êtes sur les traces des
meilleurs acteurs français vos modèles
il ya un quart est gilbert et michel
simon va vous êtes peut-être très bon
parce que dans ce film situé il et il
n'est pas vraiment sympa quoi annoncer
un pin un peu cynique
ouais ouais c'est un séducteur sa propre
foi je joue ça donc c'est intéressant
ces personnages très ambigus comme ça
manipulateur séducteur très bien écrit
sur signé quoi l'acteur c'est génial à
jouer quoi c'est raté c'est une
adaptation pièce c'est une piste qui est
une pièce soit la tue 5 molière ouais
d'ailleurs c'est vrai que c'est réaliser
d'une façon très humble c'est à dire que
bernard hachemi vraiment au service de
la pièce quoi pas de fioritures
simplement il montre les acteurs du
secteur voient là même qui tournait il y
six tournées c'est à dire que les scènes
on le faisait dans la continuité nous
faisait beaucoup de plans séquences
assez intéressant pour
pour marc fois que travailler comme sa
maman deuxième deuxième fois il faut
toujours faire référence à son film quoi
confirmer
voilà je crois que tu as complet j'ai
contrôlé si tu veux être acceptée ça y
est j'y suis seulement voilà c'était
c'est tellement agréable à faire mais
ensemble nous y voilà du plaisir
beaucoup de plaisir beaucoup de plaisir
ce que ça change quoi c'est toujours la
même chose quand ce n'est pas une chose
que podium donc un an ça qui me plaît
dans leur directeur un peu comme ce que
je faisais avec une bagnole tu vois
c'est notre personnage que je raffole
ce que tu vas faire tu va regarder ta
caméra et isabelle est bien parti à dire
en vo parce que là c'est pas possible
c'est là qu'elle m'a saisi la scène call
rouge oui tu dis magnéto serge comme les
autres oui d'accord
manitou serge je pense que vos parents
vont être aux anges oui mais ils sont
aux anges un message je fasse je
présente la météo y trouve sa sublime la
fin voilà c'est vrai que l'appartement à
dunkerque a été transformée en musée
jean c'est un grand musée on peut
visiter un ouais ouais non mais c'est
vrai en plus il ya tout là quoi il ya
les amener chez les affiches il ya même
l'enveloppent quand entre mais césar
donc ton nom et dans une enveloppe
quand on m'a dit glisser dans la poche
sais pas qui m'a glissé l'assistant
choix sur le plateau mes parents m'ont
gardé le nom encadré c'est à la maison
à quel âge avait pris conscience de vos
qualités d'acteur comme ça
depuis je suis petit j'ai envie de faire
ça oui mais j'ai pas conscience de
qualité et son film
oui oui voici mais là j'ai compris la
mer c'est bien
temps en temps des ratés aussi depuis
hwa depuis je suis gamin j'ai jamais
pensé faire autre chose en fait c'est
vrai que vous faisiez des exposés à
l'école sous le troisième reich en
imitant laspalès oui j'avais fait un
exposé comme comme je n'avais pas
beaucoup de contenu j'avais pas
travailler en fait pour faire rire j'ai
voilà j'ai fait un exposé sur troisième
reich on évite laspalès marcher courir
mes camarades way l'époque et leur à 13
ans vous faites le siège d'une origine
dans une icône extrême droite jour 13
ans fait le siège d'une radio locale à
dunkerque qui s'appelle radio corsair
jusqu'à ce qui vous donne une émission
de dimanche matin vous avez bien je suis
rentré je faisais à l'époque s'appelait
pouces disque ça allait quand on était à
la radio on parlait pas en fait on
enchaînait les disques et après ouais
j'ai commencé à parler dans le micro à
15 ans quoi je faisais de 15 ans à 18
ans fait une bonne vanne à cette époque
là là sur les employés de la mairie on
s'est fait virer d'ailleurs un côté ça
on avait dit que la radio certaines
radios locales donc été évidemment
financé par la ville
ouais voilà et on avait dit pourquoi les
employés de la mairie de dunkerque ne
regarde pas la fenêtre le matin parce
qu'il serait plus quoi faire la place à
l'os n'a pas fait marrer en fait je
crois et le premier adjoint je me
souviens qui a débarqué dans les studios
c'est inadmissible il était naturel
là vous n'êtes pas payé vous n'avez pas
le jouer comme la normale à n'ont
d'abord pas son truc
il sait comme ça avec sans façon emploi
premier radware alors votre premier
succès c'est en seconde tout bizarre
monde
je dois dire et là vous avez joué une
pièce écrite par deux copains et ça
voilà vous êtes rendu compte que vous
aviez vraiment des capacités de huawei
c'est là où ça m'a plu on a joué bon
puis c'est la conscience et est entré en
secondé tu joues devant 800 personnes un
autre plan rend compte de rien et je me
suis rendu compte mais que c'était pas
mal quoi c'est ça me plaisait et qu'est
ce qui vous a décidé à venir à paris
je voulais vie en fait je voulais venir
depuis depuis toujours mais mes parents
on dit il faut faire des études toujours
le même truc dont je suis parti allié je
fais des études pendant trois ans et
j'avais une camarade de classe de 2,1
caire qui était rentré au cours florent
et je suis allé la retrouver en fait au
moment des vacances de noël je suis allé
voir les courses des abeilles nantis qui
donnait quoi et j'ai appelé mes parents
disant voilà je veux plus retourner à la
fac je veux rester là quoi ils ont été
super parce que parce que c'est pas
évident quand tu viens de province
départ d'un milieu aisé la vie à paris
c'est quand même cher donc voilà vous
avez une chambre de bonne
12 12 12 c'est un peu ses douze mètres
carrés dans le xvième ali de versailles
c'est peut-être au dessus de chez
elisabeth c'est vrai c'est qu'on
entendait des coups de feu des rafales
et 250 financier est alors votre maire
tous les week-ends vous fait un petit
panier pour la semaine parce que j'avais
pas de sous je pouvais pas l'acheter
fallu tout ça c'était trop cher c'est
impossible
donc je rentrais le week-end à dunkerque
et ma mère me préparer des plats dans
des tiroirs pour la semaine entre la
gare du centre national du livre à 23
ans
ouais exactement mais ça permettait de
bouffer mais vous y croyez toujours à ce
moment là ouais ouais ouais des moments
tu y crois moi c'est sûr non mais toi
j'ai toujours cru je me battais quoi on
monte des pièces avec les copains on se
débrouille et ben c'est comme ça qu'on a
fait la pièce des robins des bois batave
donc il fallait se débrouiller en fait
le déclic ça a été julie lescaut sinon
c'est les robins des bois la pièce le
déclic et que farrugia qui vient nous
voir ça c'est la date à wels a tout de
suite
et voilà et aujourd'hui vous faites des
films avec depardieu quand même bon de
temps vous avez la vedette way qui sort
le 23 février qui s'attache à le faire
qu'on reste amis
ouais ouais c'était top et puis à bout
du sauvé des eaux c'est un petit rôle à
ses participations en souvenir avec
jugnot de justement de batignolles il
m'a demandé de faire un petit truc ouais
c'est vrai bien ensemble attends tu
rigoles jeu ravive mais vous jouez bien
jean-paul merci n'écoute pas les gens
qui jouent très bien
voilà jean paul rouve est devenu un vrai
pro donc on va faire une interview promo
de pro jean paul rouve est ce qu'on peut
dire que le film de bernard rate c'est
d'abord une rencontre est quelque part
un aboutissement pro un problème c'est
une rencontre c'est une rencontre avec
un personnage j'ai envie de dire
puis un aboutissement c'est dix ans de
travail acharné de vache enragée pour
arriver à ça c'est bien
onlive bernard rapp le réalisateur ce
qui vous intéressait c'était de
rencontrer bernard rapp
l'homme non j'imagine oui oui bah oui
bernard à ploemeur ça a été bernard ap
la femme j'aurais pris puisqu'un 13 vous
pensez qu'il a su voir en vous au delà
de l'image que vous avez oui oui je
pense que on a dit joe jean-paul wipro
jouit je pense que ce que bernard a su
voir en moi il a su voir en moi le
comique mais qui est a su retirer son
son nez rouge de clown gens viennent ici
mais vous a remarqué dans quelle fille
nîmes a remarqué bernard ap bernard marc
marans et on les robins des bois
est-ce que vous avez su voir si tu ton
film de merde marais depuis site pour
vous évidemment il n'y a pas de secret
avec du travail
je suis et je dirais que je suis un
artisan un artisan du rêve
ouais c'est bien artisans du rêve exaucé
bien trouvé ses classes avant tout ce
film restera une expérience passionnante
j'imagine avec une équipe magnifique et
quelque part une famille d'une saute
bien sûr la fin de la grande famille du
cinéma la grande famille du cinéma
évidemment penser que c'est le film de
la maturité pour vous jean paul je pense
que c'est le film de la maturité de la
thune parce que j'ai pris grave
jean-paul si vous arrêtez de jouer un
jour vous mouret ah oui moi je crois que
je suis comédien au fond de l'âme
c'est ma vie je suis né pour ça c'est
quand je mourrai avec sa hache sur scène
à je mourrai sur sept mois bravo molière
jean mathis si tu nous regardes jean
paul rault
[Musique]
jean rouleau mais là messieurs ils sont
encore 10 mois en préparant cette
interview je regardais tata filmographie
80 cinéma et c'est déjà très très bien
serial lover le petit poucet tanguy
astérix et obélix mission cléopâtre une
influence monsieur je suis là je n'ai
pas dit parce que quand même tu crois
que je devrais dire vis-à-vis de
dominique farrugia
ben ouais parce que j'en suis fier aussi
attend est fier aussi mais où est ce que
ça prend des fois qu'on me propose un
rôle à huila rhône hier non mais dites
le moi ni mon cours de la semaine mais
la vie j'ai fait deux films non je sais
pas le meilleur des deux voilà monsieur
batignole moi césar 10 ans et demi mais
qui a tué pamela rose podium un long
dimanche de fiançailles je préfère qu'on
reste amis le temps des porte-plumes et
nos jours heureux dont nous allons
parler ce soir c'est pas mal ça vaille
et coûte ouais ça va pas mal pas non
mais oui une autre chaîne
la bande annonce et ont fui nos jours
heureux
oui ça donne envie de le voir il est
bien merci
bon allez c'est sur l'air bien non mais
ça me fait super plaisir n'en est encore
rien vu venir la môme la vie de piaf
dont harbin chine a dit le plus grand
bien ici c'est quand même temps rien
il est là quand il a vu à cannes en fait
il a vu le promo reel à kabala il adore
écoute vraiment pour quelqu'un qui
supportait pas de se voir à l'écran ça
va mieux là tu étais habitué aujourd'hui
avoir ta gueule à salins m'habituer oui
oui c'était un excès de coquetterie
ouais ça va maintenant c'est bon quoi je
vois ça salam
ça c'est un t-shirt du film c'est pour
rebecca abel peut le mettre tout de
suite mais j'aimerais qu'elle le mail ce
changement
voilà à oui cela a un rêve et car voilà
ce que j'attends qu'ils vont fermer les
yeux à sanaa quand on est comme des
garçons dans les cartes à dire maintenir
on peut fermer les yeux et humaine c'est
chouette changé ah non non mais alors
alors va te changer de nom marne ont
changé la place alors mécanique
j'aurais essayé
j'aurais essayé mais tu vas le real va
pas changer attentif c'est pas idiot
jean paul pelliot alors peut-être ces
cabinets la grande copine de sarkozy
c'est vrai ouais irait bien
six mille personnes ce soir non il a un
film qui sort et la one man show woman
parenté pétards plus de budget je fume
pas c'est l'attitude du one man alors
bien j'étais devenu une star jean paul
ah bon maintenant la 20 minute d'accord
alors jean paul rouve offrir une maison
neuve à vos parents et/ou affaires n'ont
pas fait et je ferais pas mais pour son
annonce que mes parents sont pauvres et
j'ai envie qu'il le reste c'est pas bien
de changer ils sont trop vieux pour
changer dans la même année des cartons à
ta mère prend qu'à dorment dans la rue
samatan c'est bon tu as changé de statut
à leur âge trop traumatisant la drogue
aurait pu être fait ou à faire dans la
drogue non je fus même pas de pétard tu
vois je ne fume pas je picole un peu
mais tranquille et les [ __ ]
il avait arrêté s est ce qu'une fille
qui couche avec moi ce que je suis
connue s'appelle une [ __ ] à balard c'est
ça c'est ça la grande demande à nadine
du chef des top models fait ou à faire
non non pas fait dire tu alain delon
fait ou à faire affaire dans la sphère
j'ai rencontré mais il avait une fiche
sur moi vont se faire inviter par arthur
à saint tropez fait ou affaires n'ont
jamais fait non plus et je n'ai pas
envie d'aller à saint tropez gagner un
césar fait ou affaire a fait à un fait
ça c'est classe assis trop classe et un
start est et là d'un seul coup boom tu
montes coucher avec une fille juste
majeur fait ou à faire avec ton césar
toujours couché avec une fille juste
dans un album majeur coucher qu'une
fille juste ref ai fait faire la bise à
catherine deneuve fait ou à faire non je
connais pas claquer un million d'euros
en un mois fait ou à faire un million
d'euros en un mois ou avec catherine
deneuve ça va vite trouver une inconnue
à poil dans votre lit ou à faire un nom
à faire j'aimerais bien ses coûts c'est
ce soir
un bond qui abat un inconnu évidemment
forcément je sais pas si c'est parler de
son film aux 20 heures chez claire
chazal fait ou à faire dimanche blanche
alors elle parle du film faisant un film
et on est au 20 heures dimanche de
quelque chose ait dans le ca va tous
faire offrir en entrant dans un magasin
de fringues fait ou à faire c'est entre
les deux c'est à dire que c'est un peu
minable il va ils me disent venez on va
vous filer des trucs
il m'offre un truc et après ils me
disent le reste on nous fait 30%
ouais moi c'est un peu minable c'est
possible demi vedette web se faire payer
en liquide pour une soirée privée fait
ou à faire annoncer non pour faire quoi
dans son esprit les pouilles être
annonces non non je souffre klimek
sauter une animatrice télé fait ou à
faire jean-paul arlette chabot c'est
considérer
la couverture devrait s'y fait ou
affaires n'ont pas fait j'aimerais bien
ça je serai cet été ça nu sur la plage
de dunkerque n'ont donné son opinion sur
un sujet de société fait ou à faire
alors à faire la prostitution alors jean
paul boily [ __ ] je peux pas ou alors
gratos procès en diffamation ont fait ou
fr oui a fait avec et robin attaque
j'attends d'y avoir un coach personnel
fait ou à faire anon à faire enfin on
peut le monde voit ça t'as pas de
préparateur physique et j'ai pu manger
pas de prêt j'ai hâte à toi ouais il
bosse beaucoup d'heures par semaine
je pars de loin
c'est un boulot quand même dire non à un
rôle dans le prochain film d'alain
chabat a fait ou à faire un nom je
pourrais pas ça ouais les yeux fermés un
bon jouer au poker avec patrick bruel
fait ou affaires à faire affaire à avoir
plus de trois partenaires sexuels
différents la même semaine fées ou à
faire un peu fait fort non mais c'est
que je parle d'un temps que les moins de
20 ans évidemment avec ok c'était avant
c'était non mais c'est vrai se tenir à
l'homme politique fait ou à faire au nom
je reposte non commencer une phrase dont
ils ont écouté
moi qui suis acteur écouter nos tissus
acteurs non j'ai pas fait ça mais je me
suis surpris quelquefois être idiot des
trucs qui m'ont énervé bêtement où je me
suis dit mais c'est pas normal avec je
suis qui est en fait une deux mondes
après je lui dis mais je suis qui en
fait tu vas
dans jean-paul vous êtes ici pour nos
jours heureux d'eric toledano et olivier
nakache avec marilou berry omar omar sy
de omar et fred un de frais d omar dix
ans jacques boudet jean benguigui
joséphine de meaux sortie le 28 juin
alors le pitch nos jours heureux raconte
les aventures tragi-comiques de vincent
vous donc responsable d'une colonie de
vacances
pris en sandwich entre un staff
déboussolé déjanté et des mômes
ingérable alors il ya le train pour y
aller il ya les veillées autour du feu
il ya les courses en sac
il ya les premiers flirts enfin il ya
tout quoi c'est la colo quoi ré c'est
très émouvant même temps ouais ouais
c'est très émouvant je suis d'accord ça
plaira à vous le dis je pense ça tu vas
télé on peut l'augmenter des pieds ah
bah oui bah oui tu vas voir tu vas
adorer
mais en fait dès l'es2 real nakache et
toledano ils sont beaucoup à raison de
colo voilà et c'est en fait leurs
souvenirs qu'on retrouve dans le film
aussi une bonne comédie populaire avec
nous par issam applique des rires des
larmes de la musique ne rien dire tu as
fait une allusion film très drôle avec
la galante heures pour le bisou pour
s'embrasser comme celle ci avec marcel à
taylor ça n'a pas marché je ne marche
pas tout le temps marche pas tout le
temps ce coup là les essaye avec nadine
ça faisait une pause bisous nadine sa
détendrait tout le monde on a dit et
après on fume un pet
on leur la primature la sécurité n'est
votre situation personnelle s'est mariée
mère de famille je suis député c'est ça
ma situation personnelle
y a pas que ça dans la vie et une grande
gêne y'a un allié à une grande maison
avec ses parents les chiens trois
enfants tous savent à quoi ça va
la boule dit lui me dit tu es à moi vous
m'avez pas posé la même question je vous
ai non on est bien content que nadine et
l'ump sont pas dans le film
la sortie aux entrées de mercredi moi ça
fait un peu froid ont été gâtés jamais
allé en colo mais on a l'impression que
tu as fait ça toute ma vie d'acteur
c'est ça j'étais monsieur batignole
jamais été collabo non plus donc c'est
vrai pourtant certains tournages taman
balance
oui mais voilà c'est ça
car comment ils te vas le tiche à attend
trop bien trop bien on voit bien nos
jours heureux dans trois des agents
n'est que trois mois ouais ben moi je
suis invité mme hidara de ses quinze
questions moi c'est mina rêve
quant à trois cartes ch'tis vous devez
chanter les gens du nord tu vois et
j'entends les gens du nord cédric gracia
serait infligé le parrot la légende du
nord entend dans les yeux leurs banques
à leur décor les gens du nord ont dans
le coeur le sommet le soleil qu'ils
n'ont pas dehors ou sa légende liquide
oh on veut toujours leurs portes à ceux
qui ont souffert les gens du nord
n'oublie pas qu'ils ont vécu des années
dans
[Musique]